good morning believe nation today's
message is impossible is nothing over to
you Justin Timberlake here's maybe the
greatest thing a teen or anyone in this
room and who's watching on the
television at home can learn from the
champ these are words to remember when
anyone tries to tell you to give up tell
you to give in because whatever you're
trying to do is impossible the champ
said this impossible is just a word
thrown around by a small men who find it
easier to live in the world they've been
given than to explore the power they
have to change it impossible is not a
fact it's an opinion impossible this
potential impossible is temporary
impossible is nothing greatest ever
so as a relatively new dad and a former
team I'm here to say you will make
mistakes
along the way you will fall down I have
many times even Ali did but what we do
after that fall is how we make history
because impossible is nothing I love
love love love love this quote and it
reminds me of what I'd like to say on
the channel is that you make the big
decisions with your heart and the small
decisions with your head and it's super
important for every big decision in your
life that you're making it with your
heart because your head can only
understand a world that currently exists
because it's logical so what you think
about this thing that's never been done
before you see it's impossible because
it's never been done before
right that's what your head is thinking
and when you tell your friends and your
family and your colleagues and the
people around you both this crazy big
vision your idea that you have they're
gonna say that's impossible why because
they're using their heads too and as
long as you continue to make the big
decisions in your life with your head
and setup with your heart then you're
always going to operate in a world that
just currently exists what if you look
at the big pioneers in the world Disney
and jobs and gates and Oprah and all of
these people that we profile every
single day on this channel a thing that
they had in mind was they saw something
that didn't exist yet they had this
passion to make something new to be
creative to build a new world to build a
new way of doing something that came
from the heart and then they use their
head to figure out the how make the big
decisions with the heart and then use
your head to figure out the practical
steps of how to go out and accomplish it
impossible there's nothing it just means
it hasn't been done yet and you can be
the first to figure out how so the
question of the day today is I'm curious
what have you done in your life or your
business that other people has said
would be impossible to do leave it down
in the comments below I want to get
inspired give me some good stuff guys
I'm gonna join into the conversation
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot events
festive